it does mean that it's time that we
looked at those rules again
and ensured that we're inclusive yes
that people have a pathway to sport
absolutely but to make sure as we
rightly said that it's
fair and proper and done the right way
those rules ought to be looked at i
would say on an annual basis as more and
more research becomes available rather
than a quadrennial
or even decade length basis
but there is much more research that is
now available in this space
than there was when those rules were
originally set that shouldn't affect
laurel's participation
because she qualified according to the
rural set for her
and therefore for her she's doing
nothing wrong at all
but she's simply following the rule set
by the ioc at this
point but that doesn't mean we shouldn't
look at the rules
yeah and certainly changing the rules
over one athlete seems
entirely unfair but again
maybe this is something that has to be
looked at so let's talk about
weightlifting in particular because
obviously when we talk about
sport that covers an awful lot of
territory and so when you say
transgender athletes might have an
advantage in certain sports
over women um by birth
that becomes a question of well what
sport are we talking about weightlifting
in particular
i think you can look at most people
would look at as a lay person and say
well
i would expect that in weight lifting
someone who
was biologically born a male has an
advantage certainly through
through uh going through male puberty
which laurel did
go through male puberty you have my
understanding is
a different amount of bone density a
different amount of muscle density
as compared to uh women who are born
women cis women
and so in this particular sport
and obviously this is your area of
expertise is there an advantage that
needs to be considered especially
when it comes to transgender women in
weightlifting
so i think the first thing to say is
that
i am obviously not a phd or an md so i'm
not a doctor not a medical doctor
and therefore i defer to people with
more appropriate expertise and where
levels should be set
i think it's right to say that there's
different levels for different sports
and different
inclusion needs for different sports uh
fast twitch muscle sports like
weightlifting like track and field
um like powerlifting do have a higher
degree
to which strength and bone density
play a part versus something like
archery or shooting
i think it's highly important we find a
way to include transgender individuals
and
to that extent i think that that laurel
will be in
years to come uh seen as the first uh
person to to to go through that
inclusion pathway but
we do need to look at what those rules
need to look like for each sport
individually
or for at least collections of sports
things like swimming track and field
cycling weightlifting might sit together
with a bobsled for example from the
winter sports
whereas you might see slightly different
rules in an archery or shooting
but those have to be based in academic
research
based upon conversations from every side
of the equation otherwise inclusion
but also looking at what is really fair
to
every individual competing and the
individual circumstances
there are policies in the united states
look at the individual circumstances
which include when
somebody uh and apply slightly different
criteria based on that timing
yeah i want to read a quote here and and
this was not uh this is not my words
here but i think it makes a good point
which is it's talking about the
difference between um
having advantages physical advantages uh
which
again all athletes you know will have
some advantages over athletes or
many athletes have advantages over
others um it's how you get to
the top and if we're talking about an
olympic games certainly
in within the olympics just to make that
team you have to have advantages over
other athletes
uh but i'm going to read the quote here
it says for instance we we let
left-handed tennis players play
right-handed tennis players
even though left-handed tennis players
have advantages but we don't let
heavyweight boxers get in the ring with
flyweights
i think that do you see the statement is
interesting i think there's some truth
to that
in that there might be and i think
you're making an excellent point about
this
the research has to be done and it needs
to be quantified
in some official ways but it just stands
to reason
again tell me i'm not a weightlifter
i've never been in the olympics and i've
never
been part of any kind of sport of
weightlifting but my understanding is it
would make sense to reason that
again someone who has gone through
puberty as a male
would have certain advantages um similar
to
a heavyweight boxer against a much
lighter boxer
um you know an advantage that becomes an
unfair advantage at a certain point
you said you believe that laurel hubbard
will will kind of
be looked back on in history as having
broken i guess through
a certain level of a glass ceiling if
you will
um but do you believe that that
there could also be a backlash to her
participation in these olympics
uh in terms of at least in the in the
short term of
women and women's groups and groups who
were
anti lgbtq saying
this is problematic if hubbard does well
so first of all i don't think that i
personally don't believe that laura will
win a medal
in these olympic games i have at least
three individuals
finishing above her i also want to make
the point that
this is not just an olympic games issue
these athletes compete against each
other in world championships
in grand prix events in in case of uh
laurel and oceanic championships
cornwall championships and commonwealth
games
uh europeans as well obviously um the
u.s
uh beats independent american
championships these events happen
throughout the years it's not just the
olympic games
i do think that there is a case to be
made that laura will be
seen by those who wish to participate in
sport and are transgender or even
members of the lgbt community
wider as um as a
if you like a trailblazer for that
inclusion regardless of whether that
review of the rules we already talked
about
may or may not allow laurel's case to
proceed in the future and i think that's
the important thing is to concentrate on
the idea
that the rules may need review
based upon research not laurel herself
who has simply followed the rules
to be participating in this year's
elected games
phil andrews ceo of usa weightlifting
thank you so much for your time and
weighing in on this issue
thank you just ben all right let's bring
in our next guest it's dr
nicola williams the director of fair
play for women uk
uh and uh dr williams thanks for joining
us on being a part of this conversation
so the name of the organization fair
play i think is
kind of the standard that a lot of
people are looking at right now there
are an awful lot of people who look at
this particular issue and say
this is not fair play how do you see it
yeah well it it's not fair i mean the
reason that we have
male and female sports um is to allow
women to be able to compete on a level
playing
field and the reason we need to do that
is because
you know males people who are born male
go through a male puberty so their body
develops on testosterone
and women's don't you know that's why
we need um a separate female category
so it's quite simple really that you
know
someone like laurel hubbard did they
yeah were they born male yes did they go
through a male
puberty yes and has they
lost the advantage due to that male
publicity due to hormone treatment well
the science says
at the moment no they haven't very
little muscle strength is lost
after transition so it's clearly unfair
um and when it's unfair
and you allow males into women's sport
it means women
miss out there are women who didn't make
it to the 11th picks
because laurel hubbard took the place
and one thing just to say of course
laurel hubbard is not a cheat uh laurel
is
sticking to the rules so he you know
laurel should be there
based on the rules as they stand now but
those rules are wrong
and so the olympic committee have got
these rules wrong and they caused a mess
here
yeah it seems uh that they caused a mess
in part because
many of the rules if you will
surrounding this particular issue
um have taken very little science into
account because i know that they've set
for instance and i don't want to get
into all the minutia of it but they've
set testosterone levels
at a certain point which to say you know
your
testosterone in this um transition
female has to be low enough
but it's still far higher than it would
ever be in a natural-born
um cis-gendered woman um it's my
understanding and you can correct that
if it's incorrect but my understanding
is that even within setting these rules
there is and we talked about this term
before advantage a significant advantage
uh that would go to someone who is a
male born athlete trans transitioned
athlete
in any of these fast twitch sports
whether it be weightlifting or
another major one is track and field and
there have been a number of stories
outside the olympic games
that have discussed this as well among
college athletes and high school
athletes where
there are uh transgender athletes
who are female running in these these
races and just obliterating their
competition
because they did transition after
puberty and it does make a difference
it does and the thing is with puberty i
mean we all know this
you can't reduce you can't you can't
reverse puberty
you know so a male person when they
reach six foot one
won't shrink when they go on you know
when you reduce testosterone for example
and we know that that's the same with
many other factors including muscle
strength so
males have an enormous amount of upper
body strength
um and that's why laurel hubbard has a
massive advantage
um compared to if laurel had been born
female because that's the issue really
but so it's not about the testosterone
that's
in the body now it's it's what the body
was exposed to
during its development and that's what
where the ioc
made up made a technical error really is
that they presumed
i think they wanted a solution to show
that if you take testosterone away
hey presto you've got the equivalent of
a female athlete but it's just simply
not true
you can't do that and they made the
rules in 2015
when there was very little evidence and
now there's even more evidence to say
they were wrong um and so that's what
happens when you make decisions
based on virtually no evidence
um what they should have done is they
should have generated the evidence first
tested the concept you know can you
eliminate male advantage yes or no
but they didn't wait for the evidence
they just decided that they'd go ahead
anyway
and that's how we're in a mess now the
first olympics where you've got
transgender athletes with a clear
advantage
with much higher levels than allowed
than actual female athletes
um it's wrong on so many levels
it seems that you know our previous
guest phil andrews was mentioning that
this is
much more than just uh olympics right so
the olympics come around every four
years whether
every two years alternating that summer
and winter schedule but
in between there are many many different
competitions and and even though i
and everything i've read so far
indicates that laurel hubbard is not
expected to win a gold or a silver
but possibly a bronze medal um based on
what she's lifting right now but if you
look at some of these
world competitions in the meantime she's
won a number of these competitions
but let's set some of that aside in
terms of women and girls and
and focusing on that issue who are
feeling some of this as athletes i know
here in the united states one of the
questions
goes back to scholarships that there's a
big concern
about scholarships for um you know women
and girls
who would not be able to get those track
and field scholarships
would not be able to get many of those
kinds of scholarships
because of transgender athletes that
they simply cannot compete with
and so when we talk about it from that
point of view it does seem to have
a longer-term effect on many of these
young women's
lives does it not yeah i mean you're
right this isn't just about the olympics
what's important the reason we're
looking at it is that
it's on the public stage at the moment
we're all aware of it because the
olympics is such a big event
but actually what's happened is all of
the um
all of the other sports of all the lower
levels
uh international all the way down to
amateur level
in the various countries have copied the
rules from the ioc
so this happens at all levels in sport
in all sports um and
um it impacts people not just
it's not just elite athletes and it's
not just about
will laurel hubbard get a gold medal um
laurels are likely to get a gold medal
but even if laurel doesn't get a medal
at all
laurel has already taken the place of
of a woman who would have gone to the
olympics if the rules were different
so there's a turkish um lifter who
would have qualified um and she's
sitting at home now in turkey
not going to the olympics because of
these rules so there are all sorts of
consequences
you know it it's not that laurel will
get a gold
because actually laurel is only a rather
mediocre male lifter
um and there are better female lifters
but they are tremendously good lifters
you know the chinese woman that's likely
to get
gold is amazing um but
you know the bronze medal place it will
be competed for
with a mediocre male and some of the
best female
lifters there are including one of the
great britain lifters who's very who
lifts similar levels to to laurel so
it'll be a really interesting
competition
and i think it will really raise public
awareness of some of the issues which
i'm really glad about
last thing i'd like to ask you though is
so what what do you believe the solution
is because there has to be a solution
is the solution simply to say if you
have
gone through puberty as a male you
compete in male categories if you've
gone to puberty as a female you compete
in female categories you create a
separate category
specifically for transgender athletes
what do you believe the solution is
well we already have the solution in a
way you know we have two set
we have two categories we have a
category for people who
um have not been through male puberty
and we have a category for people that
have
and so we just have to allocate people
according to
to the right categories so the problem
is really that we're calling the
male category the men's category now we
need to stop that because there's lots
of people
that could fit into the male category so
you know people who identify as men
people who identify as trans women
people who are identified as trans men
on testosterone they've all had the
advantage of testosterone so
they need to go into that category and
then we need to reserve
the female category which is the one for
people who haven't had
testosterone benefits um and they can
compete there
so i think this is time for men to to
move over but make room in the men's
category because trans women have to be
welcomed in support there has to be a
place for them but the right place
is based on what their body is like and
that's
the male category and men
need to welcome trans women into that
category
um and that means maximum inclusion for
everybody
but fairness is returned
yeah i i hear what you're saying and i
think that uh that's
that's probably where i think many
people would follow
obviously not everyone many people would
fall in that category of believing that
that's the case um and again i think
this comes down in many ways
as we were saying before to a question
of advantage
uh whether you know as we said all
athletes
who are at the elite level have an
advantage over other athletes that's why
they're in an early level but
an unfair advantage it's why we don't
allow doping
it's why um some of those issues are not
allowed do you think that
moving forward what kind of impact do
you believe
that if these issues are not dealt with
what kind of impact will it have
on the female athletic community
worldwide
well we'll end up with the female
category
have been having females and
males and the male women
will be will be better and so they'll be
the ones that get selected
so you know we get talent scouts looking
for the best
women in sports because countries want
to
um we're in medals and inevitably those
best women
will be the ones that were born male and
that's ridiculous isn't it you know
when i say it out loud it's it's uh it's
ludicrous but that's the reality
um i think i've already heard examples
of
coaches um looking for trans women to
to start playing in their sport because
they'll have an advantage
just the same way that the east germans
years ago in the doping scandal would
recruit women
to go on testosterone um because they
knew that you could just take an
ordinary woman
put him on testosterone and she'd be
well beaten
in the same way you can take an ordinary
mail
allow them to allow them to to go into
the women's category and they'll be
world beating
so this ultimately this doesn't get
sorted out
this is the end of fairness for women's
sport
and it makes a mockery of all the
advances
that we've we've done over the years to
encourage women to
to play well and then i think that
the other part of the story that gets
overshadowed there's
there's a lot of concern that i see in
the media a lot of concern about
transgender athletes and protecting them
and protecting their right
i see very little concern for women who
just a few years ago or even decades ago
there was a lot of sympathy to say women
need to have these opportunities i mean
it's why
these categories were created there was
an awful lot it seems of
time and effort and sacrifice
made to make sure that women would have
these opportunities and it seems like
very quickly
that could go away and i and i your your
point about
coaches specifically seeking out
transgender athletes
to so that their program or their team
has an advantage it seems awfully unfair
yeah i mean this is the way it will it
will go i think
i i can't see any other any other way of
it happening
um but
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's a as we said it's
something that could be very interesting
to see you know where things head from
here
um but dr nicola williams we thank you
for your time and your input
on this issue it is certainly a
sensitive one we appreciate you
you speaking out thank you thank you
okay so um we have a couple of other
guests that we've lined up and we're
trying to get
get them um on here so i think we have a
minute here
uh before we go to them but just let me
just share a few details
again about what's happening um with
this particular
this particular story of laurel hubbard
um and guys you can just come back to me
full if you'd like
um so you know there are again
a lot of questions surrounding this and
surrounding whether or not
the rules have been made fair enough
whether or not we are able to see
uh for instance um athletes that
have certain levels of testosterone that
is low enough
for them to be able to compete but as we
mentioned you know there have been a
number of
uh well-known athletes olympic athletes
including caitlyn jenner who have
actually spoken out against this
who believe that this is actually the
wrong move uh for the olympics
to have done this and and calling this a
mockery
uh of the sport because they believe
that the advantages are so unfair
um and and it is interesting to watch
some of these
take place because the physical
advantage is certainly there
as we mentioned the chemical advantage
the testosterone advantage uh is
certainly there uh for
these athletes um the bone density
advantage
is certainly there the muscle density
advantage is there what many people may
not realize
is the level to which um that density
changes
when um a young man goes through puberty
uh and
what that process ultimately looks like
for them
uh and so it's you know fairly
interesting to watch
why the olympic committee has made the
rules the way that they have and again
not just the olympic committee but
many of the the governing bodies over
sports
seem to be driven far more by politics
than they are by science
at this point and i think that's uh
that's fairly concerning
so um yeah and dr williams again
um i we we thank you for your time
we appreciate you being with us so let's
go ahead and move to our next guests and
we have them here uh joanna harper
author of the book sporting gender
she's a phd advisor to international
sports governing bodies and a trans
athlete
herself and uh joanna i hope you've been
able to hear um
that conversation so far i would love to
get your input on this welcome to the
podcast
um i only caught a very small glimpse
of the uh the conversation but i think i
probably know where it's going okay
let's let's talk about this so in in
terms of your view
uh share with us your view because
obviously you've written about this
extensively and about the history
of of transgender athletes and um i just
mentioned right now that there are some
um you know transgender athletes who
have spoken out against this you're
i believe in favor of it but tell us why
and tell us about some of that history
here that many people may not know
um well trans athletes have been around
for a while
uh you know it was 45 years ago that
renee richards first
uh competed in the u.s
open she didn't do that well as a tennis
player
and um you know trans athletes certainly
haven't taken
over the fact that we are now just
seeing our first trans athletes in the
olympics
uh is is certainly indicative of the
fact that that
trans women are are not taking over
um and uh
if we were looking at sort of an equal
representation
we should be seeing about 30 trans women
uh
in the olympics this year and people are
very worried about
one uh so so it doesn't make a lot of
sense look it is
absolutely true that laurel hubbard has
advantages
i i mean that that's undeniable by by
anyone who recognizes anything
uh like science however um
she's certainly not overwhelmingly
advantaged in her event
uh lee win win uh the gold medal
favorite
lifts 50 kilograms more than than uh
laurel so so while laurel has advantages
um she's certainly not gonna win and
you know she may well place in the
middle of the pack but but
that remains to be seen yeah
those are all absolutely true points and
we talked about that a little bit so far
that she's not
favored to win the gold or even the
silver at this point
has a as a shot it appears at a bronze
medal uh and that's looks where
most of the competition will be but as
you're watching this do you believe
there is too much concern at this point
it sounds like that's what you're saying
because if you're saying you know one
the very first trans athlete in the
olympics
and it is grabbed a lot of headlines
um is there too much being made of this
uh
certainly for an athlete again who's not
even favored to go
to win the gold and and she's not
actually even the first
trans athlete in the olympics uh
non-binary canadian footballer quinn
uh played uh yesterday for the canadian
women and they tied japan
so um you know she won't even be the
first trans athlete to compete
but she's getting the lion's share the
attention this year
um and uh
i look i think it's reasonable
to to want to have fair competition
in the women's category and to put rules
in place that that have uh create limits
on on what trans athletes can and can't
do i think the current ioc
policy of requiring trans women to lower
their testosterone
will mitigate the advantages that trans
women have to the point where
in most sports it's reasonable to allow
trans women to compete
do you believe and and i hear that
argument because certainly that's
that's the main point that the ioc has
made correct the international olympic
committee has said
it's that testosterone level that
they're really monitoring but
hello ma'am is there not an advantage
that comes with the with the male
puberty in terms of bone density and
muscle density or do i have that right
to fix the camera a bit no you've got
that right um
so can you um but the bone density thing
first of all is kind of a two-edged
sword uh
so bone density is
is a base to build muscle on it it also
can serve as a protective
uh uh a yes
against injury and and perhaps damage
and combat sports
so there's advantages of having
increased bone density
but trans women great thank you very
much are now trying to
power this increase of bone density with
reduced muscle mass and reduce the
aerobic capacity and that can lead to
disadvantages for them too
so uh bone density is not
always a good thing um
and the the muscle mass there's
certainly a reduction
in the muscle mass uh that trans women
have
uh as a result of reducing uh
testosterone with hormone therapy
now it certainly doesn't take away it
doesn't take away the advantage but it
certainly
lessens the advantage sure and
and to that point then do you believe
that there should be rules based upon
the sport itself that a one size fits
all then
because as you're saying it creates a
certain advantage in some sports perhaps
but a disadvantage in others and so
does there need to be a more uh refined
view of the rules as opposed to a one
size fits all
absolutely in fact i have been pushing
for sport by sport regulation of trans
athletes since 2018. if you listen to a
recent statement from thomas bach
he seems to indicate that this is where
the olympic policy will be going in the
future
um we'll have to wait and see what they
do they have announced that there will
be changes after tokyo
and as i said thomas bach recently said
uh look
for uh sport by sport regulations but
we'll see what the isc comes up with
yeah i think that
that it makes a lot more sense when you
talk about it that way right because
obviously it can
the the conversation as we started this
is that some of
all athletes at the elite level have
advantages over other other athletes
uh but where has it become an unfair
advantage and so if you're doing it
sport by sport
you're able to mitigate that in a much
much cleaner way
certainly in a way that i think becomes
more reasonable
to most people because it levels that
playing field again
but in terms of social perception
do you believe that this is acting in
some ways
and i'm not saying that laurel hubbard
should not be doing this because of this
you know you can't certainly live your
life based upon the way that the society
is going to see it
but are there those who are taking
advantage as i guess the question i'm
asking taking advantage of this moment
to try to limit opportunities for
transgender athletes
um yeah of course there are people who
are
are doing that i think we're we're
seeing this
uh prominently in the united states for
instance where
a number of states have have suggested
uh
you know not just trying to ban athletes
from the olympics but trying to ban
uh young trans athletes uh from
from competing in their their identified
gender uh at very low levels of sport
where you know do we really care that
much
uh you know high school sports
team sports are hardly the olympics
yeah and team sports you would think
that there there would be again a
different treatment for those as opposed
to the
the individual sports and i'm wondering
if that's why you mentioned that laura
hubbard's actually not the first to to
compete in these olympic games
but um the the
first maybe to compete in a solo
category and maybe that's why it's
getting more attention
um uh yes and
and also the fact um that
uh quinn uh the the non-binary uh
footballer for canada
was assigned female at birth and so
there's less of a physiology issue
with them playing and and quinn uses
non-binary pronouns
uh so there's no actual physiology
issues with with quinn playing uh on the
women's team
uh so there's sociology
involved but uh but but no physiology
whereas
you know absolutely laurel hubbard went
through male puberty
and she does maintain some advantages
it's pretty much undeniable
uh and so that's where people want to
focus
and then also the fact that laurel's a a
very big woman she's
you know she's 130 kilograms and
that she certainly stands out among most
women although
as i pointed out that lee win win the
gold medal favorite is 150 kilograms
so you know laurel is certainly not the
biggest woman
uh in her category yeah absolutely true
joanna harper
author of the book sporting gender the
history science the stories of
transgender
and intersex athletes thank you so much
for your time today
you're welcome all right
we have one final guess that we want to
bring in make sure that we were saving a
little time there we're going to run a
little bit over what we normally do
uh today because we want to make sure
that we have a chance to speak to
everyone but debbie hayden is a teacher
journalist and transgender campaigner
and we wanted to bring uh debbie into
the conversation
and certainly uh because we had a delay
there um we want to make sure that we're
giving uh you know all sides
representation and debbie thanks for
for joining us i just would love to get
your your
insights on this you've heard i'm sure
some of the conversation here
uh but what is your belief in terms of
moving forward
where does the ioc go from here
i think the irc's got themselves into a
big problem in the
mix they're confusing the reasons why we
actually segregate sex
segregate sport in the first place uh
they seem to have listened to
a narrow argument that the uh the
category that we compete in is somehow
to uh
the female sex would not win very much
yeah that's absolutely true so do you
believe that
that uh these uh that transgender
athletes
who went through puberty as well should
be competing against uh
cis-born females no you shouldn't
uh people who've been through male male
puberty have an inbuilt advantage
because we've got
we've got a mill physique uh our bones
are stronger we've got more muscle mass
heart volumes lung volumes uh just to uh
just
reducing testosterone down below an
arbitrary level
uh doesn't doesn't mitigate all those
advantages
so no we shouldn't be competing in the
opposite sex class we should be
competing in our own sex class so you
believe that there should be a third
category that's then set up for
transgender specifically where the where
you play each of those sports out and
compete
separately um i guess it's it's separate
but equal rules correct
yeah i guess at the very elite level
there could be uh there could be an
argument for something like the
paralympics where transgender people
could compete
but below that level we've got a huge
you know competition goes all the way
down to grassroots competition and there
isn't the numbers for a separate
transgender category
but people can compete in their own uh
in their own sex categories
but within that there's two things which
i would campaign for one is to uh
protect the dignity and privacy of
transgender people i don't want to be uh
for example i don't want to be changing
in an open
changing room with men so i don't want
to do that and secondly to be recording
transgender times
separately so some separate recording so
we can keep records of
the fastest uh trans woman to run 100
meters
and we keep those records uh we
shouldn't be uh we shouldn't be
including
with women's records because that's a
different category and that would be
wrong
that's a very interesting statement you
just made which is
to to keep records specific to those
transgender
athletes because number it seems to do
two things one is
by not keeping those records on some
level it feels like
you're you're taking from that athlete
and their identity uh by just lumping
them in with women in general
and then secondly you are again putting
those those uh cis-born females who have
not been through male puberty
at a disadvantage where they they can't
necessarily compete as well
um and it sounds like what from what you
were saying the ioc
oversimplified it they didn't actually
look at the complexity of the
complexity of the issue they simply just
stamped it and said
if testosterone levels are here you're
good to go and it seems like a kind of a
lazy approach
yeah and they chose an arbitrary level
of 10 uh 10 nanomoles polito which
sounds like
some ridiculously round number that
they've chosen which is way above the
normal female range
which is more like one so we're talking
you know
six to ten times the normal female range
this is this is a huge difference but
what the ios the what the ioc is doing
is
they seem to be operating under the
belief that people should
compete in the in the category which
makes them feel good about themselves
that's not what it's there for
if there wasn't a disparity between male
and female we would all compete together
in open
competition but we don't and we uh we
segregate in support for one reason only
in that male bodies are different to
female bodies and that people with male
bodies have an inbuilt advantage
and reducing your testosterone by below
an arbitrary level of 10 doesn't
doesn't take away all that advantage you
know it's it's just
not fair on women to do that
do you believe that this ultimately this
particular olympics
and i've asked this question of every
guest will harm
the transgender movement in terms of
public perception
because it becomes something that people
rally around that this is unfair and
this isn't right and so it
it seems to set back the athlete as much
as maybe help them
well it doesn't do transgender people
any good uh transgender people uh
have been accepted in society we're part
of society
we play a role in society but what what
people are going to look at here is
people are going to say this is cheating
uh there's
somebody with the advantage of male uh
male physiology competing with females
and that's that's
that i think is wrong other people are
going to think it's wrong and they're
going to uh
is then going to reflect badly on
transgender people as a whole that
that's
that's natural uh you know i i
by saying this i could be uh seen as
being negative towards
laurel woodward laurel wilbur isn't
isn't the issue here really
laurel hubbard is playing by the rules
the problem is by the people who set the
rules and those people listen to uh
listen to advice
but i think this should be challenged
the ioc committee needs to be challenged
and they need to be asked
you know who persuaded you to do this
and what did they
tell you in order to persuade you to do
it
yeah you you made such important points
the the issue of the amount of
testosterone those levels about
about 10 times that's what i've read as
well about 10 times out of a normal
woman
uh and then the other issue is you know
i've heard recently and you can correct
this if this is
wrong but i've heard recently that you
know the fastest woman in the world if
you took the time that she runs in terms
of track
uh you know she's she holds the world
record for all women of all time that
have been recorded at least
in modern history but there are 3 000
male high schools
track and field stars who have the same
record right or better
um high schoolers who can outrun this
world champion and so
again to your point it's not an issue of
of wanting to hold anyone back it's an
issue of the fact that
that women can't physiologically compete
with men the same way
on certain especially those fast twitch
sports and i think that's where
where people see it as being you know
undeniably fair
what do you hope will happen moving
forward what is
the path forward in this if the ioc you
know apart from them
you know changing the rules and creating
a separate category
aside from that is there a path forward
or is that the only way
i think we need to uh we need to look at
uh trans women especially
uh you know trans men are different it's
a different case there with trans men
uh they they take and they take a
physiological disadvantage forwards
but for trans women i think we need
different a different approach to uh
including us in sport i hear about
uh about you know rules being
there to stop us competing nobody is
stopping us competing
what this stopping is competing in is
what i would consider to be unfairly
in a class which was never designed for
us
uh it was designed for the other sex and
that's what we need to look at so we
need to
stop this uh stop the approach has been
taken roll back on that
say there are two sex categories there's
a male sex category in a female six
category
and look how we can include trans women
in the male sex category
which is which is our sex because
there's been too much of women being uh
been
forced to give way uh time and time
again
and uh perhaps perhaps it's the other
sex perhaps it's my sex that should be
giving way on this and making it's best
to transform in
not asking the other sex to do that
debbie hayden teacher journalist and
transgender campaigner
thank you so much for your time you're
very welcome
guys that is our uh podcast for today
you know fascinating stuff here our
guests were uh
extremely interesting and and so we're
just uh
[Music]
okay
you